Hallelujah.
Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Hey
everybody.
Well, this lecture is titled history's
coming climax because that's exactly
what it's all about. After we've seen
all the terrible things that are
happening on this earth and how two
camps arise and how eventually the two
camps will clash and the one is so
obviously in the great minority
that it has absolutely no chance
whatsoever
and therefore the only thing that it has
is faith.
Remember Revelation 18:es 1-4. And after
these things, I saw another angel come
down from heaven having great power, and
the earth was lightened with his glory.
And he cried mightily with a strong
voice, Babylon, the great is fallen. His
fallen has become a habitation of
devils, and the hold of every foul
spirit and a cage of every unclean and
hateful bird. and the story that all the
nations have drunk of the wine of her
fornication. That the kings of the earth
have committed fornication with her. The
merchants of the earth have waxed rich
through the abundance of her delicate
delicacies.
And then I heard another voice from
heaven saying, "Come out of her, my
people, that you be not partakers of her
sins and that you receive not of her
plagues." Revelation 18 1-4.
So just before the final events on this
planet, there is a call out of the
entire Babylonian system which we have
talked about in these lectures and then
the end will come. Isaiah chapter 24:5
says, "The earth also is defiled under
the inhabitants thereof because they
have transgressed the laws, changed the
ordinance, broken the everlasting
covenant." That's what they've done.
We've seen how they've done it. We see
how the law was changed, how Catholicism
says it's above the Bible, doesn't care.
We'll change the law. and that the clash
will come between those that keep the
commandments and those that don't.
Revelation 22
11 and 12. And these chapters that we're
dealing with now, these two lectures,
we'll be dealing with the last chapters
of Revelation, but they will be filled
in with many texts from the Bible to
show a whole picture.
Let him who does wrong continue to do
wrong. Let him who is vile continue to
be vile. Let him who does right continue
to do right. And let him who is holy
continue to be holy. Behold, I am coming
soon. My reward is with me. And I will
give to everyone according to what he
has done.
So God is judging mankind. And sooner or
later a decree goes out which says it is
done. So far and no further. Those
who've made a decision for righteousness
are covered. Those who've made a
decision for unrighteousness,
they have made an eternal decision. The
time of probation comes to an end.
Let's have a look at the typology of
Egypt, which tells us something of what
will happen towards the end.
And Pharaoh said, "Behold, the people of
the land now are many, and ye make them
rest from their burdens." Exodus 5:5.
This is an interesting verse. Pharaoh is
rebuking Moses for making the people
rest from their burdens. And the word
rest there is the word Shabbat.
So in other words, Pharaoh is saying,
"You are making the people Shabbat from
their burdens, which means keep the
Sabbath. You are making the people keep
the Sabbath." And Pharaoh said, "You
will not keep the Sabbath.
You will work." And he doubled their
labors. And he said, "No more straw for
them. You gather it yourself. You will
not Shabbat." What was God's answer?
When Pharaoh made a law prohibiting
God's people from keeping the Sabbath,
what happened?
The plagues came.
And I saw in heaven another great and
marvelous sign. Seven angels with the
seven last plagues.
Last because with them God's wroth is
completed. Revelation 15:1.
So obviously in this time
after these laws have been made and
after they have been decreed
plagues will come in Egypt. A law was
made preventing the people from keeping
Sabbath. And when that law was made and
implemented the plagues came. There were
10 then because it was a typology. There
are seven now. This is the last event.
And this means that none of these
plagues touch the people of God.
And then will come the end of the world.
So the question is what will that end be
like? What does the Bible teach? What
does the world teach? We will see that
what the world teaches is exactly the
opposite of what the Bible teaches. And
it's a very strange phenomenon.
Well, doom and destruction.
And the question is, is there no hope?
Well, yes. Otherwise, we couldn't smile.
You see, Titus 2:13 says, "Looking for
that blessed hope and the glorious
appearing of the great God and our
savior Jesus Christ." That is the hope.
That's the only hope we have. That is
the solution to the problem. Now, what
it'll be what will it be like when Jesus
comes? You see, there are so many
doctrines in the world out there. The
people are waiting for the coming of the
Messiah. If you go to Israel tonight or
today and you go outside the Golden
Gate, you will see all the graves
standing over there or lying over there
because they believe that when the
Messiah comes back, he's going to enter
in through the golden gate. The gate
will open up, the dead will rise, and
they will be the first with him in the
city. Of course, that golden gate leads
up to uh the mosque where
Muhammad is supposed to have gone to
heaven, the Dome of the Rock. Well, the
Jews are waiting for a Messiah. And
everybody is talking about a millennium
of peace. Have you heard about the
millennium of peace? There is not one
religious movement that does not preach
that except one. just one.
So what happens when Jesus comes again?
Remember the Bible speaks about four
comingings of Christ. The first one is
as a babe. The first coming he comes as
a as a child and the virgin will be with
child. All those texts in the Bible. The
second one is he comes to the ancient of
days. Daniel 7:13. And I saw one like a
son of man come with the clouds of
heaven to the ancient of days. And
Daniel watches this great scene in
heaven while the little horn Catholicism
is doing its thing down here on this
earth. So Jesus is not coming to this
earth at this stage. This is a change of
activity in heaven. Jesus is going to
receive power and honor and glory and uh
probation is going to come to an end and
all these things. Then there is the
coming in glory, the second coming.
And then there is a final coming to
restore the earth and to set up the
kingdom. There are four comingings in
the Bible and you really have to take
them apart carefully. The Jews totally
ignored that one because they were
waiting for this one.
They even ignored that one and they
ignored that one. They were just waiting
for the setting up of the kingdom. But
you have to carefully pick them out and
understand what is what in the Bible.
It's not that simple. You can't just
read it and say, "Well, everything about
restoration, that's what's going to
happen." But that's what the world does
today. Isaiah 7:14, "Therefore the Lord
himself shall give you a sign. Behold, a
virgin shall conceive and bear a son,
and shall call his name Emmanuel, God
with us. Which one did that apply to?
Obviously, the first coming when he came
as a baby, but that one was ignored.
Behold, a virgin shall be with child and
shall bring forth a son, and they shall
call his name Emmanuel, which being
interpreted is God with us. Matthew
1:23.
So, at the first coming, Jesus paid the
price for sin. Did he get eradicate sin?
No.
Not that I've noticed. Have you read the
newspapers,
watched television?
No. He didn't come to get rid of it. He
came to pay the price. He was wounded
for our transgression. He was bru
bruised for our iniquities. The
chastisement of our peace was upon him.
and with his stripes we are healed.
Isaiah 53:5.
Did the Jews recognize that text? Yes or
no? No. They looked over it. Why?
Because they had an expectation that
they wanted to fulfill, but they didn't
want to accept the biblical
interpretation. Now, why will he come
again?
John 14,
in my father's house are many mansions.
We should be able to say this off by
heart. If it were not so, I would have
told you. I go to prepare a place for
you. And if I go and prepare a place for
you, I will come again and receive you
to myself so that where I am, you may be
also. That's such a nice picture of God.
I just love this picture of him that
he's so caring and he wants us to be
where he is. So that's why he'll come
again. He's coming to do what? So that
we can be where he is also to receive
you to myself. So there's a receiving
going on over there. And we need to know
how he will come again because the Bible
says, "Beware many false Christs are
gone into the world." Doesn't it say so?
So how will he come again? Well, these
are the biblical criteria. The second
coming will be universally visible.
Universally visible. Does the Mormon
church teach that? No.
Behold, he comes with the clouds and
every eye will see him. Revelation 17.
Every eye will see him. That means
there's nobody who won't know that he's
come.
Uh, how does this text rhyme with a
secret rapture?
There's a problem there, isn't there?
You can't have a secret rapture and
every eye will see him because there's
nothing secret about that.
For as lightning comes out of the east
and shines even to the west, so also
will be the coming of the Son of Man.
Matthew 24:27. Anything secret about
that? I don't think so. That's pretty
visible. He will be universally visible
when he comes. Now, the Bible says he
comes with the clouds. Now, what does
that mean? Does it mean he's coming when
it's a rainy day?
Who makes the clouds his chariot who
walketh upon the wings of the wind?
Psalms 104:E3.
Now, we have to do some Hebrew
parallelism here. So the clouds are his
chariots.
The chariots of God are 20,000 even
thousands of thousands of
>> angels.
The Lord is among them as in Sinai
in the holy place. Psalm 68:17. So what
does Hebrew parallelism teach him? Jesus
is going to come with the angels.
So when he comes, he's going to come in
glory with all his angels. And how many
will see him? Every eye will see him. As
lightning from the east shines to the
west, so shall be the coming of the son
of man.
And they shall see the son of man coming
in the clouds of heaven with power and
great glory. Matthew 24:30. You see the
picture? So this means Jesus is coming
with his angels.
That's what it means. And when the Lord
Jesus shall be revealed from heaven with
his mighty angels. 2 Thessalonians 1:7.
We have to have all the texts one after
the other lined up so that we will not
be fooled and that we will understand
exactly what will happen when he comes.
Matthew 25:31.
And when the son of man shall come in
his glory,
and how many of the angels?
>> All the angels with him, then shall he
sit on the throne of his glory. So when
Jesus comes, all the angels are with
him. How many remain in heaven?
>> None. They're all coming to this earth.
That is zillions upon zillions upon
zillions of angels. Unbelievable sight.
Wow, it's going to be something.
And when he comes in his own glory
and the glory of the father and of the
holy angels, what does that tell you?
Can you imagine the glory of the father?
Jesus is going to come with the glory of
the father. Now, if nobody can look upon
God and live when he's sinful, what do
you think this is going to do to people
that have refused to give up sin?
It's going to be a problem.
And what about those who have been
redeemed? What is their only hope of
surviving the event?
Jesus. To be covered by his
righteousness is the only hope that
there is. So, he's going to come with
the full glory of the Godhead and all
the angels with him. And the number of
them was 10,000 times 10,000 and
thousands of thousands. Revelation 5:11.
It's going to be a spectacular event
when Jesus comes. Acts 1 11. Men of
Galilee, what do you stand gazing up
into heaven? The same Jesus who is taken
up from you into heaven will come in the
way you have seen him going into heaven.
So how was he taken up? Also with
angels. They watched it. They saw him go
up. And that same Jesus is going to come
back. Not some ghost. The one who said
come put your hands here and put them in
my side and see that I'm real. This is a
real Jesus who's coming back.
So it'll be universally visible.
The second coming will also be audible.
1 Thessalonians 4:16, for the Lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout, with a voice of the archangel,
and with the trumpet of God. Everybody
will hear it. And whoever's deaf,
they'll hear it again.
So for those of you who are have trouble
with hearing this you will hear even
dead people will hear it. Meeno don't
worry you'll hear it.
Second coming will be audible. He shall
send his angels with a great sound of a
trumpet
and they shall gather his elect from the
four winds from one end of the heavens
to the other. Matthew 24:31. So, who's
going to gather God's people?
>> Is there anything secret or quiet about
this? No. So, it's going to be a very
spectacular event. And all the elect
will be gathered from all the corners.
Now, here's a very important criteria.
He will not touch the earth. He will not
touch the earth.
And the dead in Christ shall rise first.
So, there's a resurrection of the dead.
But it's the resurrection of those who
are in Christ.
They rise.
Then we which are still alive. So the
living that are in Christ at that time
remain shall be caught up together with
them. The dead that were in Christ and
the living that are in Christ will be
caught up together with them in the
clouds. Which means who?
The angels that have just gathered them
all. And what are the angels going to do
with him?
To meet the Lord in the air.
Ah, that's a rapture, but it's not a
secret rapture. It's a very loud
rapture.
And so we shall we ever be with the
Lord. 1 Thessalonians 4:16-1 17. We must
read the verses carefully. So when Jesus
comes, every eye will see him. He will
not touch the ground. He will send his
angels to gather the elect. The voice of
God raises the righteous in Christ. Only
them.
And they're all gathered. And then the
angels take them up and they meet the
Lord in the air. It does not touch this
earth. So when you hear that Jesus is
here or there or in the inner room, what
did Jesus say?
Don't go. Don't bother. It's not me.
Matthew 24:26-27.
Therefore, if they shall say to you,
"Behold, he's in the desert," do not go
out. "Behold, he's in the secret rooms,
do not believe it." It's pretty simple
not to believe it if you know the truth,
right?
For as the lightning comes out of the
east and shines even to the west, so
also will be the coming of the son of
man. Matthew 24:26 27. It's very plain.
The Bible makes no bones about it.
Nobody should have to make a mistake on
this. Now, this is another tricky one.
What will take place at the second
coming? What does the world teach?
Everybody will be converted. Everything
will be honky dory. The Bible hasn't
said anything like that up to now.
the resurrection of the righteous.
That's one of the things that takes
place when Jesus comes. For the Lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout, with a voice of the archangel,
with a trumpet of God, and the dead in
Christ shall rise first. 1 Thessalonians
4:6, the dead rise, those in Christ.
Revelation 256 will tell us about the
others. The rest of the dead
did not live again until the thousand
years were finished. So when do the rest
of the dead rise?
Obviously a thousand years later. Is
that what the text says? Yes or no?
Okay. So there are two resurrections.
The one resurrection is the resurrection
of the just. The other one will be a
resurrection of the unrighteous. But the
between the two how long? a thousand
years. Is that what the world teaches
out there? No.
Blessed and holy is he who has part in
the first resurrection. That makes
sense. Which resurrection, if you are
dead, would you like to be in?
Obviously, the first one. The second one
could be kind of problematic.
So, we want to be in the first
resurrection. Revelation 25 and 6. Who
is in the first resurrection?
those who are in Christ. Simple as that.
So the righteous living, what happens to
them? They're obviously not raised from
the dead. They are still waiting. And we
could be part of that group. You know
that. What happens to them? Well, 1
Corinthians 15:52-53.
In a moment, in the twinkling of an eye,
at the last trump, that's the same time
when Jesus comes. For the trumpet shall
sound, we've heard about that. The dead
shall be raised incorruptible, and we
shall be changed. For this corruptible
must put on incorruption, and this
mortal must put on immortality.
So, there's a change. Everything that is
mortal disappears.
If you have fillings in your teeth, then
watch out for anyone else because
they'll just shoot up and you'll get a
new set. Everything will be changed. and
nothing will die anymore.
That'll be fantastic.
What happens else? Philippians 3:20 and
21. For our conversation is in heaven.
From whence also we look for the Savior,
the Lord Jesus Christ, who shall change,
our vile body, in case you thought we
were so cool.
That it may be fashioned like unto his
glorious body. Wow, that is amazing. God
will give us a body like his own.
Amazing. This is incredible stuff.
Matthew 13:49 and 50. So shall it be at
the end of the world. The angels shall
come forth, sever the wicked from
amongst the just, and shall cast them
into the furnace of fire. There shall be
wailing and nashing of teeth.
So what does this mean?
Matthew 13:49 and 50. So, first thing
that we see is there's a separation
and it doesn't seem to be too good to be
on the bad side, right? Doesn't seem to
be too good. So, what happens to the
wicked? Now, this is a doctrine which is
highly complicated and which we'll have
to unravel. It'll take two lectures now
to unravel it, but we'll do it all today
and then we'll see what happens. Well,
the kings of the earth and the great men
and the rich men and the chief captains
and the mighty men and every bondman and
every freeman hid themselves in the dens
and in the rocks of the mountains. So
there are two categories on this earth
when Jesus comes. The one group is
saying this is our God. We have waited
for him. The angels go collect them and
what do they do with them? Take them up
and they meet the Lord in the air. And
the others what are they doing?
They're running for their lives
and hiding wherever they can. And who
are they? Well, it looks like the great
men and the rich men and the chief
captains and the mighty men and all
these people that are now saying they're
going to be the winners. It looks like
they're going to be in trouble.
And said to the mountains and the rocks,
"Fall on us and hide us from the face of
him that sitth on the throne and from
the wroth of the lamb. For the great day
of his wroth has come." And who shall be
able to stand? Revelation 6:15 and 17.
So they'd rather have a mountain fall on
them than face the Lord. That's pretty
serious.
Ever thought of that mountain rather
than face the Lord?
Well, what else happens to them?
And then shall appear the sign of the
Son of Man in heaven. And then shall all
the tribes of the earth rejoice because
the Lord is going to restore this earth.
And there will be a millennium of peace
forever and ever and no more troubles.
No, it doesn't say that. It doesn't say
that at all. Matthew 24:30. And then
shall all the tribes of the earth mourn,
and they shall see the Son of Man coming
in the clouds of heaven with power and
great glory. They're going to be happy.
They're going to be very happy. Behold,
the Lord came with 10,000s of his holy
ones to do what?
execute judgment upon all
and to convict all the ungodly of all
their works of ungodliness which they
have ungodly wrought and of all the hard
things which ungodly sinners have spoken
against
him. In this series we have called it
the total onslaught
against whom?
>> Against Jesus. Have we looked at some of
the ungodly things they have said about
him? Well, there's a day of judgment
coming for them. And they might think
they are the winners, but this text says
otherwise. Jews 14 and 15 says they're
in trouble. They're going to be
convicted. There's going to be a
judgment. There's nothing to be happy
about. There's no conversion here. There
is a judgment, an executive judgment.
The great day of the Lord is near. Is
near and hasteth greatly. Even the voice
of the day of the Lord, the mighty men
shall cry there
bitterly.
That day is a day of wroth, a day of
trouble and distress, a day of wastess
and desolation, a day of darkness and
glooiness, a day of clouds and thick
darkness. Zephaniah 1:14 and 15. Who
teaches this in the world? Have you ever
heard this doctrine preached in a
church? Never. Nobody preaches it. But
that's what the Bible says. All you have
to do is read it.
2 Thessalonians 2:8. And then the
lawless one, the one who changes the law
of God will be revealed. What happens to
him? What happens to the one who dared
to change God's law and says, "I'm above
the Bible. I can do it. Who cares? I can
change the precepts of Christ." What
happens to him?
Let's see. whom the Lord shall consume
with the breath of his mouth and shall
destroy with the brightness of his
coming. Two Thessalonians 2:8. This is
tough. Tough medicine.
Really tough. So he might have a loud
mouth now,
but he's not going to have a loud mouth
for very long. Jeremiah 25:33, "And the
slain
of the Lord shall be at that day,"
that's always pertaining to the second
coming. Whether you read it in the Old
Testament or the New Testament, there's
perfect harmony.
From the slain at that day, will be from
one end of the earth to the other end of
the earth. They shall not be mourned nor
gathered nor buried. They shall be as
dung on the ground. Jeremiah 25:33.
Why will they not be gathered?
There's nobody to gather them. Why will
they not be buried?
There's nobody to bury them. Where are
those that could perhaps bury them?
They're gone.
And not secretly either. Is it biblical
so far? I'm just reading the Bible.
I will utterly consume all things from
off the land, says the Lord. I will
consume man and beast.
I will consume the fowls of the heaven
and of the fishes of the sea and the
stumbling blocks with the wicked, and I
will cut off man from off the land, says
the Lord.
Did the animals sin? Why is the Lord
going to destroy all the animals as
well? You see the animals through sin
are suffering
and the animals have become degraded and
diseased. If you look into your
paleontology, you will find that the
animals were huge in the past.
Everything was much much bigger than
today. I bet you no dog ever got hip
displacement.
I don't think animals suffered then as
they suffer now. In his mercy, God is
going to end this entire creation.
So, what is going to be left on this
earth that's alive when Jesus comes?
Nothing except something. But I'll come
to that in a moment.
So, everything is going to be destroyed.
Does that sound like the story that is
being preached in the world out there?
No.
Right. Psalms 110. The Lord is at your
right hand, and he will shatter kings on
the day of his wroth. He will execute
judgment among the nations, filling them
with corpses.
He will shatter chiefs over the wide
earth. Psalms 1105 and 6. So, what's
going to happen to all these people that
had such loud mouths against him?
They're going to die. They're going to
die. Jeremiah 4:23-8 I beheld the earth
and indeed it was without form and void
and the heavens and they had no light. I
beheld the mountains and indeed they
trembled and all the hills moved back
and forth. I beheld indeed there was no
man and all the birds of the heaven had
fled. Is there harmony between the
prophets? Yes or no? Absolutely. And I
beheld and indeed the fruitful land was
a wilderness. And how many of the
cities? All its cities were broken down
at the presence of the Lord. By his
fierce anger, for thus says the Lord,
the whole land shall be desolate, yet I
will not make a full end. For this shall
the earth mourn, and the heavens above
be black, because I have spoken, I have
purposed, and I will not relent, nor
will I turn back from it. So although
everything is killed here, it's not over
yet. There's still more to come. Lots of
interesting things are going to happen.
And we have to unravel it. So now the
secret rapture Matthew 24:38-42
as for as in the days of the flood they
were eating and drinking, marrying and
giving into marriage until the day that
Noah entered the ark and did not know
until the flood came and took them all
away. So also will the coming of the son
of man be. They will all be taken away
as we saw. Then two men will be in the
field. One will be taken, the other
left. Two women will be grinding at the
mill, one will be taken, the other left.
Watch therefore, for you do not know
what hour your Lord is coming. This is
the text that they use to substantiate
the secret rapture.
Where does it say one will be taken
secretly and the other one will be left?
Does it say that? No. All it says one
will be taken, one will be left. In
other words, the righteous one, what
will happen to him?
Angels will gather him and take him
what? To meet the Lord in the air. The
unrighteous one, what happens to him? He
has to remain here and be dead. That's
it. There's no secret rapture here. Is
there any disharmony between this and
what we've read? No.
Dispensationalists claim that Antichrist
will arise after the secret rapture.
But the Bible clearly teaches that this
power will arise from the church, not
after the church.
1 John 2:18 and 19. Little children, it
is the last hour, and as you have heard
that the antichrist is coming, even now
many antichrists have come by which we
know that it is the last hour.
They went out from
us,
but they were not of us. For they had
been of us, they would have continued
with us. But they went out that they
might be made manifest that none of them
were of us.
So if dispensationalism teaches that the
Antichrist will come in the future, and
he will come not from the Christians,
but from another society that will
persecute the Jews. That is what they
claim. That's not biblical. It's not
biblical. And in any case, the
Antichrist doesn't come in the future.
He arose as we saw
in Roman times already. He comes out of
the fourth beast. He comes out of Rome.
So dispensationalism cannot be right. It
cannot be because it's not biblical. But
you know that the virtually the entire
Pentecostal world and the Baptist world
teaches this. It's not biblical.
There is no second chance gospel. The
secret rapture teaches a second chance
gospel. It teaches that those who are
sinful will get another chance.
And as it is appointed unto men once to
die, but after this the judgment.
There's no second chance. Hebrews 9:27.
You decide now or never.
Let the wicked forsake his way and the
unrighteous man his thoughts, and let
him return unto the Lord, and he will
have mercy upon him, and to our garden
he will abundantly pardon. Isaiah 55:7.
There is no multiplechoice here.
The just and the wicked revealed at the
same time. God is just. He will pay back
trouble to those who trouble you and
give relief to you who are troubled and
to us as well. This will happen when the
Lord Jesus is revealed from heaven in
blazing fire with his powerful angels.
Is there any second chance here? Yes or
no? No. So, the secret rapture, is it
biblical? Yes or no?
Decide from the text. There it is. Very
simple. The Bible cannot lie to itself.
Let both grow together until the
harvest. And at the time of the harvest,
I will say to the reapers, first gather
together the tears and bind them in
bundles to burn them, but gather the
wheat into my barn. Matthew 13 and 30.
Verse 30.
Is that secret? Is that a secret rapture
with a second chance? Yes or no? No.
Everything happens when the Lord comes.
So virtually the entire Protestant world
is teaching a Jesuit doctrine. Alcaza
and Ribera futurism preourism. Both
started by Jesuits. Both being taught in
the Protestant world. It's not biblical.
It's a lie. Blatantly to dup people into
not obeying the precepts of word of God.
The secret rapture. God's people, those
who have washed their robes in the blood
of the lamb, have to go through the
tribulation. They are not raptured
before it. Question.
Were the Israelites raptured away
when the plagues fell? Yes or no? No.
They were there and they saw a
difference between them and the other.
And then they were taken away. And what
happened to Pharaoh and his army? He was
destroyed. That's a typology. It's a
little enactment of a greater reality at
the end of time. Then one of the elders
answered saying to me, "Who are these
arrayed in white robes and where did
they come from?" And I said to them,
"Sir, you know," So he said to me,
"These are the ones who came out of the
great tribulation and washed their robes
and made them white in the blood of the
lamb. They have to go through the
tribulation. They're not spared. the
tribulation. The secret rapture or the
rapture theory teaches that Christians
will be spared. The tribulation will be
taken away. It's not biblical. You have
to be here in that day. They will say,
"Surely this is our God. We trusted in
him. He saved us. This is the Lord. We
trusted in him. Let us rejoice and be
glad in his salvation." Two groups. The
one wailing, the other one rejoicing.
Isaiah 25:E9.
So there is no secret rapture. There is
a glorious coming of the Lord and there
is a destruction of the living wicked.
The living dead
uh
stay dead. That's not actually a bad way
to say it, right? Uh the dead that died
in sin stay dead for how long?
>> Thousand years. What are the signs of
his coming? Well, you can read them in
Matthew 24, Mark 13, Luke 21. There will
be war and distress of nations. There
will be earthquakes as in the days of
Noah. The gospel will be preached
worldwide. There will be tribulation.
There will be false Christs and there
will be signs in the sun and the moon
and the stars. Those were some of them.
We've dealt with many of them in these
lectures. And uh these are the issues.
Matthew 24 2 and 3. And Jesus said to
them, "Do you not see all these things?
Truly I say to you that there shall not
be left here one stone on another that
shall not be thrown down." That was a
typology of what's going to happen to
this earth. God is going to destroy it
utterly. And as he sat on the Mount of
Olives, his disciples came to him
privately, tell us, "When shall these
things be? And what shall be the signs
of your coming and of the end of the
world?" Matthew 24. So there was the
temple. That's a replica of the temple
when uh it was destroyed by Titus.
They started by burning it. They were
supposed to be preserved, but they shot
burning arrows into it. It burnt like
pitch. The gold melted and ran down and
ran between the stones. And after the
fires were over, the soldiers turned
over every single stone to gather the
molten metals. Here is the manora, an
emblem of it on the Titus arch where the
slaves are carrying it back to Rome. The
great day of the Lord is near. It is
near and hastenth greatly. Even the
voice of the day of the Lord. The mighty
man shall cry there bitterly. It's a day
of wroth, trouble, distress, wastess,
desolation, darkness, glooiness, clouds,
thick darkness. It's not going to be a
good day. And there shall be signs in
the sun and the moon and in the stars
and upon the earth, distress of nations
with perplexity, the sea and the waves
roaring, men's hearts failing them for
fear. Not a joyful time. Mark Luke 21:25
and 26.
Matthew 24:7, "Nation shall rise against
nation and kingdom and against kingdom."
This is an interesting text. Isn't that
a duplication?
No, it's not.
And there shall be famines and
pestilences and earthquakes in diverse
places, nation against nation, kingdom
against kingdom. The word nation there
in the original is the word ethnos.
Can you see it? ethnic group against
ethnic group
and then kingdom against kingdom. That's
a defined border. Yes, there will be
wars amongst nations. But within
nations, you will have ethnos against
ethnos. here the Tootszies and the Hoous
and the terrible congregations and the
hatred that is being built up between
races and between cultures and all these
things. This will boil over in the last
days in Christ. We must rise above these
things. There is no black, no white, no
yellow, no nation, no nothing. We are
all brothers and sisters in Christ and
only in Christ can it work. Amongst
Luca's followers, it cannot work. Even
Ed Gahoo said, "Read, pray, and weep as
you consider America's dreadful
spiritual plight." James 5:3, "Your gold
and silver have corroded, and their
poison will be a witness against you and
will eat your flesh as fire. You heap
treasures up in the last days." So there
will be economic woes. Behold, the hire
of the laborers who have reaped down
your fields, which is of you kept back
by fraud, crith, and the cries of them
which have reaped are entered into the
ears of the Lord. Economic woes, labor
unrest, jobs in an age of insecurity,
false Christs, false prophets, great
signs, wonders. We've had whole lectures
on it. Matraeas appearing, Marian
visions, you name it. All the great
religions posit the idea of further
revelation to be given by a future
teacher.
Hello. The Bible doesn't posit that
idea. Just all these great religions,
but they're all teaching something
contrary to the Bible. Christians hope
for the return of the Christ. The
Buddhists look for the coming of another
Buddha, the Lord Matra. Muslims await
the Imam Madi. The Hindus, the
reincarnation of Krishna, and the Jews
the Messiah. They're all going to be in
for a big surprise
because none of that is going to
materialize except in deception.
But when the Lord comes, they will know
it. Second Timothy 3. And know also that
in the last days perilous times shall
come. Men shall be lovers of their own
selves, covetous, boasters, proud,
blasphemous, disobedient to parents,
unthankful, unholy. We see all these
things today without natural affection,
truce breakers, accusers, continent, the
list is just endless. Heavy,
high-minded, lovers of pleasure, form of
godliness, denying the power thereof,
universal peace, no universal pistols,
and then many will be offended and will
betray one another and will hate one
another. Matthew 24:10. That's the worst
of it. Do you know that this gospel is
going to be divisive?
Can you see it? How divisive it's going
to be and how people will be defended
and how people will be betrayed and end
up in jail. Cops out of control. You
think you'll be safe when you're in
jail? I don't think so. If God isn't
with you, you're not safe. This was this
massacre in Japan when they killed all
those with gas. The earth shall be old
like an garment. There will be economic
woes. There will be ecological woes,
false influ hurricans, more storms,
great catastrophes. And in the middle,
the irony. Jesus loves you.
How the beasts grown, the herds of
cattle are perplexed because they have
no pasture. Flock of sheep are made
desolate. The Lord to see will I cry,
for the fire has devoured the pastures
of the wilderness. Great fires, the land
less milk, honey. This was Australia
with the last El Nino. That's what it
looked like. And the fires in California
and bad blood and AIDS. Let no one
deceive himself. We are drifting towards
a catastrophe. Walter Litman. Few
additional signs. Increase in knowledge,
increased demonic activity, departure
from the faith, economic woes, rise and
false teachers, increase in traffic and
speed. I quite like that one. And
disobedience and anarchy.
But thou, oh Daniel, shut up the words
and seal up the book even to the time of
the end. Then knowledge shall be
increased. The word of God will be made
plain. There will be literal knowledge
as well which will increase. And that
will help to spread the gospel. And
there will be many unclean spirits and
frogs and all these beasts and false
prophets and all these strange things
when the Lord comes. They are spirits of
devils working miracles. I like this
one. Psalm 2:4. The chariots shall rage
in the streets. They shall justle one
against the other. In the broadways they
shall seem like torches. They shall run
like the lightning. Did he see this?
I don't think so. I think he saw
something like this. Fast traffic. Be
patient until the coming of the Lord.
You also be patient. Establish your
hearts for the coming of the Lord draws
near. James 5:7.
And when these things come to pass, then
look up and lift your heads, for your
redemption draweth nigh. Luke 21:28.
The Lord is coming soon. And the greater
details we will look at in a moment.
Well, we have looked at the signs of the
Lord's coming,
and we have seen that when these things
begin to come to pass, then look up and
lift up your heads, for your redemption
drawth nigh. Luke 21:28.
And then we could say,
"I have fought a good fight. I have
finished my course. I have kept my
faith. Henceforth there is laid up for
me a crown of righteousness, which the
Lord, the righteous judge, shall give to
me when?"
At that day. So did Paul
expect to receive his crown upon his
death?
>> No.
>> No. You're expected to receive it at
that day. And not to me only, but unto
all them that love his appearing. So the
reward comes when? When the Lord comes.
What does the world teach? Something
totally different. They teach when you
die, what happens to you? You go to
heaven and you have your reward. And
then you have to come back when the Lord
comes and jump back into your body.
And then you got to be resurrected.
And then you got to stand before God.
It's all very confusing, isn't it?
Doesn't make any sense. It makes no
sense whatsoever.
So at that day you get your reward, not
before. Behold, I come as a thief.
Blessed is he that watches and keepeth
his garment, lest he walk naked, and
they shall see his shame. Revelation
16:15. So some people won't even know
that he's coming. For yourselves know
perfectly that the day of the Lord
cometh as a thief in the night.
So this is often used, you know, for the
secret story. For when they shall say
peace and safety, then sudden
destruction comes upon them as travail
upon a woman with child and they shall
not escape. But notice this verse. But
ye, brethren,
are not in darkness that that day should
overtake you as a thief. So if you know
your Bible, should you be caught
unawares? Yes or no? No. Shouldn't be a
surprise. But those that are expecting
wonderful things and a millennium of
peace and all of these things, will they
be surprised? Oh, yeah. They're going to
be surprised. Very surprised.
For the father judges no man, but has
committed all judgment unto the son.
John 5:22.
Papacy says the judgment seat belongs to
it. No, no, no, papacy, you're wrong.
All judgment belongs to the son. But the
judgment shall sit and they shall take
away his dominion, papal dominion, to
consume and to destroy it to the end.
Daniel 7:26. This is a reference to the
little horn power the papacy whose
dominion will be taken away. Daniel 7 13
and 14. And I saw in the night vision,
and behold one like the son of man come
with the clouds of heaven, and he came
to the ancient of days, and they brought
him near before him. This is not the
coming of the Lord. This is something
totally different.
And there was given him dominion and
glory and a kingdom that all people,
nations, and languages should serve him.
His dominion is an everlasting dominion
which shall not pass away and his
kingdom that which shall not be
destroyed.
So the coronation takes place in heaven.
Jesus takes off his priestly robe and he
puts on his kingly robe.
probation ends and then plagues come
upon this earth and after that the Lord
comes again and behold I come quickly
and my reward is with me to give every
man according to his work shall be
Revelation 22:12
the Bible says there will be a time of
trouble such as never was since there
was a nation even to that same time
Daniel 12:1
so in this time after this close of
probation there will be a terrible time
of trouble. Plagues will fall. We'll go
into the details of that uh later. A
thousand shall fall at thy side, 10,000
at thy right hand, but it shall not come
nigh thee. Internalize these promises.
Only with thine eyes shalt thou behold
and see the reward of the wicked. This
is the biblical story. Because thou hast
made the Lord, which is my refuge, even
the most high, thy habitation, it is
worth it to follow the Lord. Even though
it looks improbable,
and it looks like we are in trouble on
this planet, this is the hope. There
shall no evil befall thee, neither shall
any plague come n thy dwelling. Psalms
91:10. Isn't that a great promise? So
all mayhem is going to break loose on
this planet. But you have nothing to
fear if you are in Christ.
Now when Jesus comes again, it's called
the battle of Armageddon. What does the
world teach about the battle of
Armageddon?
They're going to say there's a going to
be a war in the Middle East. And uh
first they had the Turks. And when the
Turks weren't powerful enough anymore,
then they had the Russians. And the
Russians are going to come and they're
going to fight and everybody's going to
meet in this valley Armageddon in the
valley of Megiddo and there's going to
be a mighty war and that then the
kingdom will be built up on on earth.
Question,
is it in harmony with what we've just
read?
We've read that when the Lord comes,
what happens to every city on the entire
earth?
>> It's flattened. That's what the Bible
says. Every city is flattened. Would
that include earthly Jerusalem perhaps?
Obviously, yes. The earthly Jerusalem is
going to go.
What was the blessed hope of Abraham?
What was he waiting for? An earthly
Jerusalem or was he waiting for a
heavenly one? He was waiting for a
heavenly one. By the way, who's building
that city?
I've gone to prepare a place for you. So
what is this battle of Armageddon?
Then they gathered the kings together to
the place that in Hebrew is called
Armageddon.
Revelation 16:16.
The Greek word for place is topos.
And topos has a literal meaning as well
as a metaphorical meaning. So the latter
means a state of mind.
So you can have a state of mind
that will lead to something. So Satan
will induce a state of mind in the
people of the world that will compel
them to seek the death of those who
refuse to obey their dictates. Does that
make sense?
So topos
is state of mind.
Joel calls it the valley of Jehoshaphat.
Okay. Zechariah states that the nations
will be gathered to Jerusalem,
meaning that they will fight against
God's people. Now, either the one or the
other. I will gather all nations and
bring them down to the valley of Yoshif.
Joel 3:2.
I will gather all nations to Jerusalem
to fight against them. Zechariah 14:2.
Is the Bible contradicting itself?
I don't think so. You see what the Bible
is doing here? It's describing a
typology
at the valley of Jehoshaphat. That is
where God intervened and fought on
behalf of the children of God. Jerusalem
is a type of God's people. God will
intervene and fight on behalf of God's
people. Who destroys the wicked one with
the brightness of his coming? Jesus. Is
it the Russians?
No. It says the Lord will destroy him
with the brightness of his coming and
not some antichrist power that will be
overcome somewhere in the Middle East.
And the sixth angel poured out his vial
upon the great river Euphrates and the
water thereof was dried up that the way
of the kings of the east might be
prepared. Revelation 16:12. Oh, that's
the Russians. Oh no, that's the Turks or
whatever they wanted it to do. But it's
not in harmony with the rest of the
Bible.
Now, here is the actual valley. And up
there, Ahab had his uh fortress. This
was one of the troughs that the horses
were tied to where they could feed or
drink or do whatever. Water systems were
up there. That's where the great wars
were fought. So, this valley of Megiddo
is a very interesting place. And when
you are in the valley of Megiddo, there
is one mount
that seems prominent and that's Carmel.
And at Carmel, there was a decision
where Elijah said, "Choose thee this day
whom you will serve." It's the value of
decision. That's where it is. Decide for
the one or the other. Let us come near
together for judgment.
Who raised up the righteous one from the
east?
called him to his foot, gave the nations
before him, and made him rule over
kings. He gave them as the dust to his
sword, and as a driven stubble to his
bow. Isaiah 41:1 and2. What is Isaiah
implying here? Who is this king of the
east?
It's the Messiah. It's Jesus. Yes, it's
the Messiah. Are we absolutely sure?
Let's have a look. Here is Ezekiel 43:1
and2. Afterwards he brought me to the
gate, even the gate that lookth towards
the
>> east. And behold, the glory of the God
of Israel came from the way of the east.
Who's he coming with?
He's coming with all his angels. And
he's coming with the glory of the father
as well and his glory. And his voice was
like the noise of many waters and the
earth shined with his glory. So, who are
these kings from the east that are
coming?
Jesus and his angels. Jesus and his
angels. That's the only harmony that you
can find. Behold, the Lord came with 10
thousands of his holy ones to execute
judgment upon all. There's not going to
be no literal
armageddon with all the nations of the
world gathered in a tiny little valley.
They wouldn't fit in there in the first
place. and to convict all the ungodly of
their works of ungodliness which they
have ungodly wrought and of all the hard
things which ungodly sinners have spoken
against him. That's what's going to
happen.
And he had been clothed in a garment
dipped in blood and his name is called
the word of God
and the armies of heaven. Are we getting
the picture? What war is this going to
be? It's going to be a heavenly war.
heavenly intervention. The armies of
heaven followed him on white horses
clothed in fine linen, white and clean.
So this war is God intervening. So
Armageddon,
the mountain of decision here on this
earth is when Christ intervenes on
behalf of his people. And out of his
mouth goes a sharp sword so that with it
he should strike the nations and he will
shepherd them with a rod of iron. And he
treads the wine press of the wine of the
anger and of the wroth of Almighty God.
Destruction.
And the great city, which city is this?
Babylon. This is spiritual Babylon. All
of them come together came to be in
three parts. So what's going to happen
to Babylon
when they see the chips are down?
this alliance between the dragon powers
and the beast power and the false
prophet power. What's going to happen to
that? It's going to fall apart. It's
going to disintegrate.
And the cities of the nations fell. And
the great Babylon was remembered before
God to give her the cup of the wine of
the anger of his wroth. This whole
alliance, this confederacy of secrecy
and lies is going to be exposed for what
it is and it's going to fall apart and
voices and thunders and lightning
occurred and there was a great
earthquake such as has not been since
men were on the earth so mighty and so
great an earthquake. Revelation 16:18.
So the carpet's going to be full pulled
out from under every city
and the cities of the nations fell
and every island fled away. That's an
interesting one. And the mountains were
not found. So the mountains are going to
go down. This earthquake is going to do
something and the islands are going to
disappear. Two possibilities. Either the
islands go glue glu glue glue
or else what
the continents shift together and
everything is moved to one side. Two
possibilities I don't know which maybe
even third and fourth one. And then a
great hail, that's the seventh plague,
as the size of a talent, that's about J
big blocks of ice,
came down out of heaven on men. And men
blaspheme God because of the plague of
the hail, for the plague of it was
exceeding great. They don't honor God
because these people that are struck by
this final plague,
they don't acknowledge him. So they
blasphe,
"Have you entered into the storehouses
of snow? Or have you seen the
storehouses of the hail which I have
kept for the time of trouble against the
day of battle and war?" Job 38:22:23.
Armageddon is a war fought by God using
earthquake and hail to destroy those who
destroy want to destroy God's people.
Revelation 6:17, "And the great day of
his wroth has come, and who shall be
able to stand?"
The beast, Catholicism, was taken, and
with him, the false prophet
was taken. The two were thrown alive
into the lake of burning
fire
with brimstone.
And the rest, who's that?
kings of the earth, the merchants, all
the others were slain by the sword of
him who sat on the horse, it proceeding
out of his mouth. Okay, who's missing in
the triad up there?
>> The dragon's not there. The dragon is
the demonic forces that have gathered
the people into all the spiritualistic
union. He's not there. The beast,
Catholicism,
and fallen
Apostate Protestantism that went into
alliance
and all the Babylonian forces are
destroyed.
But the demonic forces, they remain.
Even so, the Lord God Almighty, true and
righteous, are your judgments.
Revelation 16:7.
The rest of the dead, remember, did not
live again until the thousand years were
finished. This is the first
resurrection. Revelation 25.
By the way, this looks kind of strange.
This is the first resurrection. You must
remember that Revelation is written as a
kayazm and we're actually reading
backwards. So, the ideas are back to
front. The rest of the dead are not
alive, but blessed and holy are those
that had passed in part in the first
resurrection. The description is
reversed.
So the living wicked die, the dead
wicked remain dead a thousand years.
And
the dead in Christ shall rise first.
Then we which are alive and remain shall
be caught up together with them in the
clouds to meet the Lord in the air. And
so we shall be with the Lord forever. 1
Thessalonians 4:16-1 17. So the
righteous go up to heaven, the dead
righteous, the living righteous
translated at the same time. Up they go.
The rest are slain. So the righteous
dead raised together with the righteous
living. They are translated and meet the
Lord in the air. Is that biblical?
Okay. And there they spend their next
time with God. What are they going to
do? Well, we'll have to see. It shall be
said in that day, lo, this is our God.
We have waited for him, and he will save
us. This is the Lord. We have waited for
him. We will be glad and rejoice in his
salvation. Isaiah 25:9.
Either you belong in the group that
rejoices, or you belong in the group
that weeps and wales.
2 Timothy 1:12. For I know whom I have
believed, and I am persuaded that he is
able to keep that which I have committed
unto him against what? That day. What
day are they always talking about? the
coming of Christ. There is no such thing
as when you die, you go to heaven, or
when you die, you go to hell. When you
die, you're in your grave. When you are
resurrected, you either are in the
resurrection of life or you are in the
resurrection of death. One of the two.
Now, we're going to continue this story
and we'll see the greater picture of
what's going to happen in the
millennium. What is the story about
hell? We're going to deal with that in
great detail. Does it exist? Does it not
exist? And then we're going to see
what's going to happen in the final
reconstruction of the kingdom of God.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Oh,
glory.
Heat. Heat.
Oh,
hey.
hey. Oh.
Hey,